If you were searching for a hidden gem buried
within the streaming slushpile, you could
do a lot worse than Lockout, a 2012 masterwork
of French science-fiction that's currently
burning up the charts at Netflix.
When Netflix released their Top Ten list this
week, viewers were surprised to find the underappreciated
foreign film showing a strong 8th place.
As of May 19th, Lockout breached the streamer's
most-viewed list, joining the ranks of hotly
anticipated Netflix originals like The Wrong
Missy and recognizable franchises like Despicable
Me.
The popular streamer only recently lifted
up its digital curtain to make at least a
tiny sliver of their tightly held viewing
statistics public.
Since earlier this year, they've been promoting
a weekly "Top Ten" of their most watched content,
albeit without revealing the actual numbers,
and the results have definitely been interesting.
So far, the rankings have been dominated by
a predictable mix of buzz-worthy original
content and licensed properties with broad
family appeal.
Films like Lockout surprise us when they crack
the list, because they don't fit comfortably
in either box.
So, what business does a little-known French
film from eight years ago have climbing the
rankings to such heights?
As it turns out, Lockout is actually a pretty
wild ride, and U.S. viewers who likely missed
its original release have been there for it.
The 2012 action film is the directorial debut
of French filmmakers James Mather and Stephen
Saint Leger They hired Luc Besson of The Fifth
Element fame to assist with the screenplay,
though both Mather and Saint Leger are also
credited as writers on Lockout.
For a first foray, the greenhorn directors
landed a pretty blockbuster cast.
Lockout stars Guy Pearce as protagonist Snow,
opposite Maggie Grace as Emilie Warnock.
They're joined by Vincent Regan, Joseph Gilgun,
Lennie James, and Peter Stormare.
Pearce's Snow is a man framed for a crime
he didn't commit in a far future world.
He is offered the opportunity to earn his
freedom if he rescues the President's daughter
Emilie, played by Grace, from a notorious
orbital prison known as MS One.
MS One has been taken over by a violent gang
of inmates in full revolt, and Emilie is currently
their captive.
Gilgun and Regan play Alex and Hydell, the
inmate ringleaders who engineer the prison
riot and take Emilie as a bargaining chip.
"Don't get me wrong, it's a dream vacation,
I mean, I load up, I go into space, I get
inside the maximum security nuthouse, save
the president's daughter…"
If you think some of these elements sound
familiar, legendary sci-fi director John Carpenter
agrees.
"You go in, find the president, bring him
out in 24 hours and you're a free man."
"24 hours huh?"
"I'm making you an offer."
He successfully sued Mather and Saint Leger
for plagiarizing the story of his classic
genre films Escape from New York and Escape
from LA. Carpenter was eventually awarded
€20,000 for the infringement, in addition
to the €10,000 awarded to screenwriter Nick
Castle and the €50,000 awarded to MGM.
An appeal of the decision was rejected back
in 2016, bringing the matter to a close.
Reasonable minds can differ as to whether
the European courts ruled rightly in this
case.
It should be noted that European intellectual
property law tends to be much more unforgiving
than U.S. law.
What might qualify as an infringement in the
European system could be deemed a tribute
under the American paradigm.
If Mather and Saint Leger were going to look
to older works for inspiration, they could
do a lot worse than Carpenter's films.
Whether you consider it a ripoff or a tribute,
the results on display in Lockout speak for
themselves.
Lockout was originally released to 2,308 theaters
in the United States and Canada.
Over its brief run, it only made $14 million
domestically, adding another $18 million to
that total, worldwide.
"With that kind of attitude, I can see why
people don't like you."
"Oh come on, people love me."
Critical response was mixed at the time, though
most reviewers lauded Guy Pearce's performance
in the lead role as Snow.
Derek Malcolm at the London Evening Standard
wrote that,
"It's laughably over the top but Pearce, a
decent actor, anchors it somewhere between
Escape From New York and The Transformers."
Some critics speculated at the time that Lockout
suffered from unflattering comparisons to
Carpenter's Snake Plissken movies, but others
saw merit in what Mather and Saint Leger were
trying to accomplish.
Sarah Gopaul at Digital Journal wrote,
"For a night of shameless entertainment and
explosions, Lockout is a winning choice."
That seems to be exactly what Netflix viewers
are after.
Eight years after the film's initial release,
it appears that streaming audiences have decided
that Lockout deserves a second look, and many
of them officially like what they see.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.